Hi, do you have any chocolate bars?
Sure, what kind are you looking for?
I'm looking for one without nuts.
Here you go.
How much are these?
That would be 50 cents each.
I'll get six of them.
That would be $3 total.
Here's $3.
Thanks!
Hello.
Could you please help me?
I need some paper.
What type of paper do you need?
Some paper I could use on my printer.
I have just what you need here.
How much is this?
$10.
Here's $10.
Thank you so much!
Wow, that blue hat looks so cool!
Yes, it's one of our latest styles.
Would you like to try it on?
Oh, I would love to!
See?
It looks good on you.
How much is it?
It's $40.
Hmm, I'm not sure if I can afford that.
I'll give you a $5 discount.
Okay.
I'll take it.
Thanks!